الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا قالت
السلطات القرم ان القوات الاوكرانيه
استهدفت الليله الماضيه
الرابط بين شبه جزيره القرم ومقاطعه خير
سن دون وقوع اصابات ومن جهه ثانيه فلت
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه بانها تقدمت
مسافه كيلو متر في اتجاه ميلوتوبل
وبيبرديانس جنوبيه رغم تاكيد وزير الدفاع
الروسيه ان الهجمات الاوكرانيه تتباطا انا
من الجزيره حسان مسعود ومعنى من تونس
هنالك تصريحات ايضا عن تباطؤ الهجوم
الاوكراني وان كان في حوزه اوكرانيا مزيد
من القدرات لشن مزيد من الهجمات لكن لنبدا
مع
ما حدث لجسر هل ساقط هذا الجسم
نعم حقيقه هذا الاستهداف بالغ الاهميه
يمكن القول على الرغم من تاكيدات السلطات
المحليه المواليه لروسيا ان هناك طريقين
اخرين يمكن سلوكهما ولكن اليوم المواقع
العسكريه الروسيه تتحدث عن ان هناك مخاطر
يمكن القول مرتبطه بنقل العتاد والاسلحه
لان هذا الجسر هو خط امداد رئيسي للقوات
الروسيه ليس فقط
واستهداف هذا الجسر سيصعب نقل الاسلحه الى
عدد من هذه المقاطعات التي يجري فيها قتال
مستعر الجسر لم يسقط ولكن الحقت به اضرار
قال رئيس القرم ان هناك امكانيه لاصلاحه
في الايام المقبله اليوم بالارتباط مع هذا
الاستهداف لهذا الجسر هناك على الرغم من
التاكيدات من قبل كان الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين او حتى سيرجي ان النشاط
العسكري والميداني للقوات الاوكرانيه قد
تقلص في الايام الماضيه ولكن وفق اعلانات
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه هذه القتال مستمر
وعلى عدد من الجبهات اليوم تحدثت عن صد
نحو 11 هجوما على مختلف الجبهات بينوجيا
وبين دانيتك وايضا اليوم اللافت زين ان
هناك منطقه باتت داخل هذا الصراع وهذه
المواجهه بين القوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه
هذه المنطقه تتصل بين لوغانس مقاطعه لوجان
سكواشمال مقاطعه هذه المنطقه في الايام
الماضيه يجري كان الحديث عن تحركات فيها
وصدها هجمات فيها اليوم اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع صد خمس هجمات في هذه المنطقه هذا
الامر ايضا تحدث عنه الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتون الذي قال انه جراء تكبيد
القوات الروسيه للقوات الاوكرانيه خسائر
كبيره في الميدان الا ان روسيا الا ان
اوكرانيا والغرب سيستمر
روسيا حتى اخر اوكرانيا هذا يمنح هذه
المعارك المستعره على مختلف الجبهات
يعطيها بعدا جيوستراتيجيا وايضا بوتين قال
ان في هذه المرحله يمكن القول ان هناك
هدوء ايضا في هذه الجبهات هذا المعطى تحدث
عنه سيرجيو هذا المعطى تحدث عنه
القتال في الميادين ولكن ولكن القوات
الاوكرانيه ما زال باستطاعتها وهي قادره
على شان هجمات وايضا القوات الروسيه تستعد
لمثل هذه الهجمات فنستمع الى ابرز مقاله
شيكو
بعد التنفيذ اعمال قتاليه على مدار الايام
السته عشر الماضيه وبعد تكبيره خسائر
كبيره خفف العدو من وتيره نشاطه وبدا في
اعاده تجميع صفوفه بطبيعه الحال لا تزال
لدى العدو القدره على القيام بمزيد من
العمليات الهجوميه على الرغم من الخسائر
الكبيره التي تكبدها في المعدات والافراد
بالطبع الاستعدادات جاريه لمزيد من
الاعمال الهجوميه بما في ذلك من جانبنا
تحول الى حسان مسعود في زابولوجيا والقوات
الاوكرانيه تتحدث عن تقدم بمقدار كيلو متر
واحد جنوب ذابولوجيا وايضا عن معلومات عن
هجوم روسي وشيك على محطه النوويه
التطورات زين على عدد من المستويات في
اوكرانيا وهي مرتبطه ببعضها البعض لا سيما
هنا في منطقه زاكوروج نحن الان جنوب شرقي
عدنا قبل قليل فقط من اقرب المناطق الى
الجبهه تحديدا جبهه التي تحاول القوات
الاوكرانيه التقدم عندها منذ فتره منذ بدء
هذا الهجوم المضاد ولكن القوات الاوكرانيه
هناك عندما تحدثنا اليها اكدوا لنا ان
الوضع عند الجبهه معقد للغايه نظرا لان
القوات الروسيه كانت طوال تلك الفتره التي
لم تكن تشهد عمليات منذ سبعه اشهر وحتى
الان على طول خط هذه الجبهه كانت تعد لهذا
الاحتمال احتمال الهجوم المضاد
تحفر الخنادق وكذلك تعد التحصينات وتنشر
الالغام في تلك المنطقه هذا ادى الى عدم
استخدام
الضربات
الاليات المعدات بقوه خلال هذه الفتره
القوات الاوكرانيه تستخدم في هذه الاثناء
الطائرات المسيره المدفعيه بشكل كثيف عند
هذه الجبهه هذا ما اشار له ايضا المتحدث
باسم قوات عمليات الجنوب منطقه تافريا هذه
التي تشمل
عن وضع هذه الجبهات وسنستمع لمقال ولكن
قبل ذلك ايضا نشير الى ان الرئيس
الاوكراني حذر من ان القوات الروسيه تريد
ان تقوم بما وصفها بالاستفزازات في محطه
النوويه وهذا التصريح هو على مستوى عالي
من الخطوره بدايه لابد من التاكيد ان
القوات الروسيه هي من تسيطر على هذه
المحطه وهذا في حال تم يعني ذلك وفق
الروايه الاوكرانيه وفق الحديث الاوكراني
ان القوات الروسيه ربما ستنسحب من هذه
المحطه وستقوم بهذه الاستفزازات او ان
شيئا اخر يمكن ان يحدث بهذه المحطه ولكن
هذه المحطه هي اكبر محطه نوويه على مستوى
قاره اوروبا باكملها في حال تم ذلك فان
ذلك لن يكون بمثابه ما حدث في نوفاكاخوفكا
وسد المياه هناك والاثار الكبيره التي
حدثت على البيئه انما اثار اكبر من ذلك
بكثير لذلك هو حذر من ذلك واشار الى هذه
المساله وهو يرتبط ايضا باحتمال شن هجوم
او هجمات مضاده على تلك المنطقه وبالقرب
منها حيث ما زال القصف متبادل بين ضفتي
النهر بين القوات الاوكرانيه والقوات
الروسيه على كل الاحوال حول الواقع عند
الجبهه التي اشارت لنا القوات الاوكرانيه
قبل قليل انها تتقدم ليس فقط بالامطار
انما ايضا بالسنتيمترات كان المتحدث باسم
هذه الجبهه قد قال ان القوات الاوكرانيه
تقدمت كيلو متر واحد في اطار عمليات
تكتيكيه عند خط هذه الجبال نستمع لمقال
المتحدث باسم قواتي تافريا المنطقه
الجنوبيه الشرقيه فاليريشن
تواصل قوات الدفاع التابعه لاتجاه التفريق
عمليتها الهجوميه في اتجاهات ايميل الطبول
وبريديانسك تقدمنا مسافه كيلو متر اتجاه
العدو ضمن اجراءات التسويه خطوط الجبهه
على المستوى التكتيكي هجم العدو وامريكا
اللتين تشهدان مقاومه شرسه من قبل قواتنا
ولم نخسر اي موقع من مواقعنا في ذلك
الاتجاه
شكرا لحسان مسعود من وجهها